but first up he's a neuroscientist
author an atheist whose new book is
science and the soul selected writings
of a passionate rationalist I am proud
to call him my friend Richard Arkin hi
Richard how I am professor great to see
you oh of course all right first of all
I have to say I love the title of this
book science and the soul because you
know it makes you go what well that's
the point yeah that's the point so tell
us what you why you put soul in a book
from such a famous rationalist and
scientist and obviously I don't mean
fell in the sense of immortal soul so
we're Americans Irving's obvious soul is
the is the catch in the throat when you
look up at the Milky Way it's the it's
the swelling in the chest that you get
when you listen to a Schubert quartet or
read a Shakespeare sonnet I'm fed up
with religion hijacking the soul in this
sense there's sometimes say to me you're
an atheist
how can you appreciate Beethoven as
though it has anything to do it really
that's the people I've had that yes
that's ridiculous
well I know people say to me all the
time why can't we reconcile science and
faith and you know we went through this
with George Bush when he said we should
teach evolution as well as creationism
side-by-side but you a controversy yeah
yeah right that's what they caught yes
you really can have have it both ways
can you faith is the very opposite of
science faith is belief in something
without evidence rhymes insists all the
time on evidence it's based upon
evidence logical reasoning from evidence
faith and science are completely
incompatible you think that would be
non-controversial but I know throughout
history we have people who don't care
for science don't believe in science
have no use for it it seems like
nowadays it's seen as something that is
actually threatening people are
literally hostile to it well very much
seven and you see this in the climate
change debate or your own poll and you
see various Trump is very Catholic
Church II
various some intellectuals with more or
less anti-science and extolling the
virtues of personal opinion subjective
opinion as opposed to objective truth
and that's been giving being given a
sort of stamp of approval by some
academic disciplines yeah I know you are
fighting this with something I think
it's called the teacher Institute for
evolutionary science yeah you actually
are teaching people how to go into
schools and teach well that's right I
mean it's run by a marvelous woman
called Bertha Vasquez in in Florida who
is a teacher and the rationale is that
middle school teachers have to teach
science and they can teach other parts
besides that when it comes to evolution
they meet hostility from parents from
children and so they don't dare do it
and so they need to be taught how to
teach evolution to what Bertha does is
to run workshops for middle school
teachers and prime them arm them with
how to teach evolution how to answer the
various ridiculous objections that
they're going to meet for example but
when you meet ridiculous objections they
come from ridiculous people I know I and
I don't I've never seen a case where
logic swayed them no but these there's
that I want I once got into trouble and
indeed I was sued for 51 million dollars
for saying that people who don't believe
in evolution are either ignorant stupid
or insane that was taken as an insult
but actually of course it's a simple
statement of fact
it really it really is because by far
the most important member of that little
trilogy is ignorant all ignorant or
something but all ignorant of growing
out of most things we're all ignorant
most things I'm a certainly ignorant of
baseball and it's something that I would
like to remedy and learn somebody can
tell me about it
I could be right with the infield fly
rule okay okay so another one of your
projects I know you rescue bloggers
secular bloggers this is mostly yes this
is everything done by the Center for
inquiry which is the the organization
that my foundation has just merged with
it's called secular rescue and there are
a number of people in mostly Islamic
countries who are in days of their lives
because they are blogging secularism
free thinking atheism Bangladesh
Pakistan places like that and what the
secular rescue program does is we don't
actually do a scarlet pimpernel we don't
go rushing in with sort of chariots and
seize them and what we do provide money
and we do provide documents and find
them places to go in Europe or America
and that's something that's actually
happening I mean that's something that
we can't people can't argue it there is
an underground railroad
basically what you're providing here for
people who just want to blog about
secular thoughts in the Muslim world and
yet you like I was disinvited for an
event we have that hidden culture where
do we do it agile ona at the school that
that 50 years ago was known most for
free speed Berkeley yes now it was it
would not get into that I don't know
whether he's for us or against us that's
not it but I don't want to give them too
much publicity because they don't
deserve it but a radio station and we're
going to do an interview to promote your
book and I won't name them they don't
deserve it they're horrible but here's
what they said we cancelled the book
event we didn't know that Hugh had
offended and hurt in his tweets
other comments on Islam so many people
we don't endorse hurtful speech wien
vatika lisa port serious free speech
obviously [ __ ] not what we do not
support abusive speech that aren't the
word abusive means yeah and obviously
they don't understand the concept that
sometimes the truth hurts what in a
university all places yes and not the
only one in this country that's going
clear like it's a it's an epidemic
that's going on of people running scared
from open speech running scared of
anybody who might come along and say
something that poor little didn't is
fine defensive what did I think a
university is for so what is it how are
we going to shovel our way out of this
mess because these are the people who
are on our side that's the problem
that's what I wanted to say I think that
the this radio station and these
universities they're on our side we're
on their side now I was the platform
specifically because of what I what I
the letter said about Islam I think that
they're the reason they did it was
probably a laudable motive they are on
the side of oppressed minorities they
think that Muslims are an oppressed
minority oppressed by people like us
actually of course Muslims are oppressed
by Islam exactly that's right yes yes
and criticism of the religion is not the
same thing as bigotry you know I went
through this with the Catholic Church
ten years ago they wanted to throw me
off television and they were like you're
anti-catholic I'm not anti-catholic I'm
anti-child [ __ ] and I'm going to
point out who's guilty of that and I'm
not Islamophobic I'm anti keeping women
instead of second question exactly and
trailing gay people of building yes and
and of course we're not saying they all
do that now but and the ones who don't
are being persecuted by the ones who do
that's where the persecution comes from
so with it these people have identified
the wrong victims of persecution throat
it's laudable that they're on the side
of people who are the victims of
execution but they've got the wrong
persecutors you know why no one reads a
newspaper anymore if it doesn't come
through all the president on youth all
right what a great way to end Richard
Dawkins thank you very much I love you
sir I appreciate you coming by Richard
Dawkins that is your book